ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد يقول الله
تعالى في الايه الثالثه من سوره الرعد من
كتابه وهو الذي مد الارض وجعل فيها رواسي
وانهارا ومن كل الثمرات جعل فيها زوجين
اثنين يغشي الليل النهار ان في ذلك لايات
لقوم
يتفكرون
ران يقول تعالى وهو
الذي وهو اي الله سبحانه
وتعالى هو الذي مد الارض اي
بسطها وجعل فيها رواسي وانهارا
الرواسي هي
الجبال
التي ترسي الارض اي تمسك الارض ان
تتحرك من تحت
اقدامنا فهي
رواسي اي فهي جبال شامخات وتعمل كالوتد
وقد سماها الله سبحانه وتعالى في بعض ايات
كتابه
اوتادا وجعل فيها
انهارا وهذه الانهار تصفي الارض وتسقي
الارض وهذه الانهار يستقي منها الناس
وفيها منافع كثيره لا
تعد والله سبحانه وتعالى يدلل بهذه ليس
على وجوده وانما على وحده نيته في في
العباده في استحقاق
العباده الله لفظ الجلاله
علم على المعبود بحق سبحانه
وتعالى الله اصله
الاله
الاله اللام
هنا
لام
للعهد الذهني الاله يعني صاحب او ذو
الالوهيه والاله في لغه العرب
المعبود محبه
وتعظيما يم يسمونه
الها ولهم الهه
متفرقه لكن
الاله فكانوا
يطلقونه ولا يريدون الا خالق السماوات
والارض بذلك
اللفظ وعلى عاده العرب في الاختصار في
كلامهم
والتسهيل فيما يكثر
استعماله
فحذفوا
الهمزه
الاله حذفوا هذه
الهمزه ف ادمج اللوام في
بعضها
فقالوا بدلا من الاله
الله
الله ايش يعني اسم الله يعني المعبود
بحق حبا
وتعظيما
وهذا قد يراد في بعض الايات قال تعالى وهو
الله في السماوات وفي الارض ايش يعني وهو
الله في السماوات وفي
الارض هل يعني ذلك ان الله
موجود بذاته في السماوات وفي الارض لا ليس
هذا مرادا ولم يقل بهذا احد من علماء
التفسير لا سلفا ولا خلف وانما وهو الله
في السماوات وفي الارض اي هو المعبود بحق
حبا وتعظيما في السماوات وفي الارض واما
هذه الالهه الباطله فان انها معبوده في
بعض بقاع الارض فقط فهو الله في السماوات
وفي
الارض يقول وهو
الذي اي هذه الالهه التي تزعمون وتعبدون
من دون
الله هي لم تفعل شيئا من
هذه هي لم ترفع
السماوات وهي لم تستوي على العرش
وهي لم تسخر الشمس
والقمر وهي لا تدبر
الامر وهي لا تفصل
الايات
وليس اللقاء بها يوم
الحساب وليست هذه الالهه التي مدت
الارض وجعلت فيها رواسي
وانهار بل الله سبحانه وتعالى الذي صنع
ذلك
وفعل باقرار
ايها مشركون انتم تقرون بذلك اذا اذا كنتم
تقرون بكل هذا كيف تعبدون سواه
معه من يستحق العباده مع
الله لذلك كما ذكرنا
سابقا
توحيد
الانبياء توحيد
الانبياء ليس منتهاه اثبات وجود الرب كما
يظن كثير من الناس هذا
خطا هذا ليس غايه في التوحيد وليس جديدا
بل الذين ينكرون وجود الخالق قله قليله
جدا في تاريخ
البشريه بل الانبياء والرسل لم ياتوا على
اقوام ينكرون الصانع ينكرون
الخالق اتوا على
اقوام يثبتون وجود الخالق ولكن يشركون في
عبادته معه
غيره سواء كان ذلك الهه اخرى اشياء من
قبور او ملائكه او انبياء او صالحين او ما
شابه ذلك
والا ف اكثر الامم وكل الديانات الرئيسيه
مش بس الديانات كما يقال
السماويه النصرانيه
واليهوديه لا وكذلك حتى الهندوس وعندهم
اكثر من 20
مليون
اله 20 مليار
اله عفوا 20 مليون
اله عند الهندوس ومع ذلك فعلماء لا يثبتون
الا راسا واحدا لهذه الالهه
كلها
ولهم تسميه تختلف من قطر الى اخر لكن
المهم هذه الالهه كلها تستجم في اله
واحد فعلى كل حال وجود
الخالق هذا ليس هو الايمان بالله بعض
الناس يظن ان الايمان بالله اذا فسرنا هذه
الادله بانها براهين على وجود
الخالق اذا فسرناها بانها براهين على وجود
الخالق
ماذا
يكون
يكون اننا نفسر الايمان
بالله الايمان بوجوده وهذا ايضا
غلط الايمان بوجود
الله
جزء من الايمان بالله ليس هو غايه الايمان
بالله سبحانه
وتعالى
بل الايمان بوجود الله هذا
جزء من الايمان
بالله لكن حقيقه وغايه الايمان
بالله هو ايش عباده الله وحده دون ما سواه
هذا هو الايمان
الكامل فمن عبد الله وحده دون ما سواه كان
مؤمنا الايمان الكامل
المطلق واما مجرد اثبات وجود الخالق فهذا
لا ينفع شيئا في الاخره
وحده لذلك لو جاء النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم الى صناديد قريش وقال يا
قومي امنوا بوجود الخالق ما انكروا عليه
ابدا ما انكروا عليه
كيف ينكرون عليه
وكانوا في في في حجهم
يقولون لبيك اللهم لبيك لبيك لا شريك
لك الا شريكا ملكته وما ملك هكذا كانوا
يلبون فجاء الاسلام وقطع الزياده ها
وجعلها لا شريك
لك
فلا اله الا الله اي لا معبود بحق الا
الله وليس معناه لا خالق الا الله هذا شيء
ما نازع فيه الا القليل والذين هم اشبه
بالمجانين منهم بالعاقل في وجود الخالق
يقولون هذا كله هذا النظام كله جاء هكذا
عشوائيا ما قال بهذا احد من العقلاء
انما في اواخر الزمن وفي هذا الزمن انتشرت
هذه النابته
والا ف قديما وحديثا هذا لم ينازع فيه الا
القليل واما الامم فيثبت وجود
الخالق بل يعبدون
الله نعم يعبدون الله لكن يعبدون معه
غيره
لذلك تجد مثلا ان قوم قوم هود ماذا
يقولون
يقولون اجئتنا لنعبد الله وحده ونذر ما
كان يعبد
اباؤنا قوم هود هكذا قالوا له اجئتنا
لنعبد الله وحده هم كانوا يعبد دون الله
لكن يعبدون معه
غيره اذا اجئتنا لنعبد الله
وحده ونذر ما كان يعبد
اباؤنا هذا هو معنى الاله الاله
المعبود فجاء
في ما قال الانبياء
لاقوامهم
والى عاد اخاهم هى قال يا اعبدوا الله ما
لكم من اله
غيره وايضا صالح اعبدوا الله ما قال امنوا
بوجوده اعبدوا الله هذا هو
الايمان الله سبحانه
وتعالى اذا قال الايمان بالله الايمان
بالله الذي يؤمن بوجود الله ويؤمن بان
الله هو الخالق
والرازق يؤمن بصفات الله لكن يعبد غيره
معه هل هذا يعتبر مؤمنا في كتاب الله ليس
مؤمنا لذلك هؤلاء قوم
هود لما قالوا لهود عليه السلام اجئتنا
لنعبد الله وحده ونذر ما كان يعبد
اباؤنا ماذا قال الله فيهم لما دمرهم قال
قال في نهايه هذه الايات في سوره الاعراف
قال وما كانوا
مؤمنين نفى عنهم الايمان مع انهم اثبتوا
وجود الله وكانوا يعبدون الله لكن يشركون
معه غيره اذا ماذا كانوا كانوا
كافرين لم يكونوا
مؤمنين اذا
عباده توحيد الانبياء
وليس محكور في فقط اثبات وجود
الخالق فالذي يقرا ايات القران ويراها
انها
ادله وكان الله
تعالى يستدل بهذه البراهين العقليه على
وجوده فهذا يكون فيه النقص في فهم هذه
الايات الله سبحانه وتعالى ليس يقول
بلسان الحال الله الذي رفع السماوات بغير
عمد ترونها اي اثبت وجوده كيف مش موجود هو
الذي رفع السماوات بغير عامد ترونها هذه
لا تكون
ادله قويه بهذه
الصفه بل الدليل على وجود
الله ادله والمقصود بها يعني الايات التي
هي في هذا المجال في التدليل والاستدلال
على وجود الله من البراهين العقليه موجوده
في القران لكنها اقل بكثير لانه لم ينازع
بذلك كثير من
الناس فمثلا قول قوله تعالى ام خلقوا من
غير شيء ام هم الخالقون ام خلقوا هذه في
اثبات وجود الخالق
نعم لكنها قليله في القران بالنسبه
الى البراهين العقليه
على توحيد الخالق في العباده هذه كثيره
جدا في
القران
لانها هي
التي يحتاج
اليها اقوام الانبياء ما لكم من اله
غيره يقول تعالى ومن كل الثمرات جعل فيها
زوجين اثنين يعني جميع
الانواع يغشي الليل النهار
اي يغطي الليل
النهار الغشي في لغه العرب بشكل عام الغين
حرف الغين كل كلمه تبدا بالح بحرف الغين
فه هذه الكلمه فيها معنى التغطيه فيها
معنى الغطاء من ذلك مثلا الغفر
والغيم
والغم وال الغشي كلها كلها فيها
معنى تغطيه الشيء فهنا يقول يغشي الليل
النهار ان في ذلك لايات لقوم تفكرون لايات
على ماذا على وجود الخالق لايات على
وحدانيه الله في العباده انه هو الذي
يستحق العباده وحده دون ما
سواه نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم صلى
الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد سه
الر
us ver of the qur are actually
discussing what they speaking about what
what
the of these
verses
many
قران for the simple reason that we misst
the context of the verses we are reading
‏so for
instance many us because the the time
and place in which we live the kind of
environment that we are
living we
imagine belief in
الله he that for the first
time me
bel there
theat
‏and that is not ex bel الله bel
الله ان الله سبحانه وتالى
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله
‏that
is people historically
have disagreed with that is quite the
minority of human beings and the human
mind
to re the
existence
of the creator this is is very rare in
the history of human thought
‏the human being natural the human being
nature the human being nature is to
believe a
creator very unlikely to
find a child that is a
dises exist of
creat
الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله
[Silence]
‏believe in
those what do me they believe
الله wor الله
any only
this الله سبحانه وتالى ased as per
his
صحيح مسلم عمر ضي الله عنه
جيل صلى الله عليه
وسلم
one
bel صل الله عليه
وسلم
الامان
الله wor
الله
لاملام لا اله
الله لا اله
الله
الله لا اله الا الله translates lally to
there n rightfully wor
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى
ar قران are
geared
ex
‏not very necess there are some verses
in the quran speak about that some but
they are much fewer far fewer than the
verses speaking
about the
logical
the
evidences and the the
deduction method meth of deduction
الله ابو جهل ابو
لهب ابو سفيان ابي بن
خلف
all that prop صل الله عليه وسلم
asem when he announced his
prop some
‏these indiv was the of between him
between them and and the prophet عليه
وسلم what was the issue that they took
exception to it wasn't the existence of
a creator they all believed in that
there was
no there was
no had no qus no ises with that
all is that
‏to
was the
issh
allah not wor any other ids any other
people any other graves any other things
and all that goes into true monotheism
this is what they took issue in the
issue was not worshiping even they
worship the is
الله محد صل الله عليه
وسلم اله الا الله none wor الله worship
الله any partn don't worship else this
is the is that they
took exception to and so the evidences
of the قران maor
maic arum
‏belve deduction and some of these
arguments that we see coming from other
parts of the world who had a bger
problem with affirming the existence of
allah existence of a creator rather the
arguments are more
about being arguments for
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى and he is the one who has
stretched out the earth what is this is
an argument for this is an argument that
look you all agree we all agree that
allah is the one who has stretched out
the earth and he has placed in it
mountains to keep it to keep it from
moving and he has placed in it
‏r all different types
he causes the night to overt the
day indeed in that there are clear
evidences for a people who think people
who
‏toid for that alone has these things by
your
admission the prophet عليه وس came to
the ide was look according to your
standards according to your bel allah is
the only one who did this therefore why
should anyone else be worshiped along
with him
شاء الله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد